Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So next month I'm going on a brief tour with
Nat Wolff, Shailene Woodley, and Ansel Elgort,
who play, respectively, Isaac, Hazel, and
Gus in The Fault in Our Stars movie.
And people get to decide where we're going,
and I have to remember to talk about that,
but first I wanna talk about prisons.
Boy, today's video is gonna be funny!
Hank, a lot of times when we talk to non-profits
about outreach, they're like we're gonna make
a GIF ("guy-f") of poop on a stick because
clean water is important, and poop is funny,
and your audience will like that, because
you guys are funny.
Then I'm like a) I think you mean GIF ("jif")
or GIF ("gif"), I mean words belong to their
users, but GIF ("guy-f") is a stretch, and
b) I don't think that funny stuff actually
works; people just want you to talk about
what you care about.
It's not like we rely on pratfalls to get
laughs or whatever.
Anyway, I've lost the thread.
I really liked your video about prisons but
there were a couple things...oooohhhh!
Ow.
Oh.
That actually turned into a very painful pratfall.
That better have been funny.
Right, anyway, I really liked your video about
prisons.
It spurred some interesting discussions, and
I wanted to add a couple things.
First, there was a lot of talk in comments
about the role of race in sentencing, and
the data there is pretty overwhelming in the
U.S. A 2013 study by the U.S. Sentencing Commission
found that African-Americans on average received
sentences 20% longer than white people who
committed similar crimes.
Also, they found that that disparity is actually
increasing.
Socio-economic class is also a big factor
in sentencing, and the question of length
of sentence brings me to one other point I
want to make.
Per capita, a bunch of European countries
actually admit more people to prison per year
than the US does, but their sentences are
much shorter; and that's one of the big reasons
we have the highest incarceration rate in
the world.
It isn't that we sentence so many people to
prison, it's that we sentence them for so
long.
And in the US that's driven largely by long
sentences for drug offences.
I've put some links in the doobilydoo for
those who are interested.
Alright, moving on to TFIOS movie stuff, so
quick catch up Hank: I wrote a book called
The Fault in Our Stars; which by the way comes
out in paperback today, that's probably what
I should have made my video about, but whatever,
I wanted to talk about prisons.
And GIFs ("guy-fs"), apparently.
Anyway, the movie adaptation of The Fault
in Our Stars comes out June 6th, but like
the hullaballoo and travel leading into the
movie for me like now.
And as part of that hullaballoo, Nat, and
Ansel, and Shailene, and I are going to be
visiting several places around the U.S., doing
I don't really know what yet.
But it will be fun, I'm sure!
And Fox is letting people choose where we
go based on Tumblr notes for various states,
so you can go to the link in the doobilydoo,
find your state, like and reblog it, and that
counts as, like, two votes for your state.
Now, Hank, you would think - and I would think
Fox probably thought - that the votes would
like up according to the population of each
state, but at least so far, no!
There are some very well-organized small states,
which is awesome, because I would like to
visit North Carolina!
Anyway, selfishly, Hank, I want Nerdfighters
to decide where we go, so Nerdfighters, if
you don't mind, go like and reblog your state
on the Tumblr.
What's that?
Oh, apparently it's not called "the Tumblr",
Hank, it's just "Tumblr".
Nah.
I grow old, Hank.
I grow old.
I am literally wearing the bottoms of my trousers
rolled.
Hank, I don't even know what this video is
about today.
Like, what do you call a video like this?
"TFIOS Prison Movie"?
I just had a great idea for a movie!
Alright, Hank, I have to drop everything and
go write my TFIOS Prison Movie screenplay,
I'll see you on Friday.